j'ouvre notre second débat il porte sur
une réforme que le Président de la
République hésite à mettre en place
celle de l'euthanasie après avoir lancé
le débat national sur la fin de vie
Emmanuel Macron avait euh promis un
texte pour la fin de l'été il se fait
toujours attendre avant d'expliquer les
ses hésitations euh voir ce qui pourrait
ce que pourrait contenir une nouvelle
loi on va détailler déjà le cadre
juridique existant la loi Clais leéonéti
avec
FAM c'était une promesse d'Emmanuel
Macron faire avancer en France le droit
à mourir dans la dignité une cause qui
doit trouver comme je l'ai promis une
traduction dans une loi de liberté et de
respect il existe pourtant déjà un texte
qui encadre la fin de vie voté en 2016
la loi clè Leonetti renforce les droits
des malades contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique mais à certaines
conditions quand la maladie est
incurable que le pronostique vitale est
engagé à court terme et que les
souffrances sont réfractaires à tout
traitement dans ce ce cas précis la loi
autorise de mettre le patient dans le
coma et d'arrêter ses traitements dont
l'alimentation jusqu'au décès ce cadre
là ça justifie d'arrêter des traitements
qui sont administrés au patient et qui
maintiennent la vie du patient de façon
artificielle on va arrêter des
thérapeutiques qui sont déraisonnables
et qui maintiennent la vie
artificiellement pour probablement pas
de bénéfice derrière mais la loi ne
répond pas aujourd'hui à toutes les
situations par exemple quand la maladie
est incurable et que les souffrances ne
peuvent être traitées mais que le
pronostic vital du patient n'est pas
engagé à court terme on parle pas d'une
fin de vie dans les jours qui suivent
mais d'une fin de vie dans les mois voir
années qui suivent et là dans ce cadre
là on n'a pas aujourd'hui en France une
loi qui permet finalement de raccourcir
cette période et d'accéder à une fin de
vie au moment où où le patient le
souhaite la nouvelle loi devrait
apporter une réponse à ces patients sans
solution pour éviter le recours à une
euthanasie à l'étranger comme en
Belgique ou en Suisse voire à une
euthanasie
clandestine faut-il autoriser une
exception d'euthanasie on en débat avec
corinebert bonsoir vous êtes sénatrice
apparentée à l'air de la charante
maritime et co-auteur du rapport fin de
vie privilégié une éthique du soins
rapport sénatorial évidemment Denis
label bonsoir et bienvenue ancien chef
de service des hôpitaux de Paris
coprésidentir l'association euh le choix
et auteur de ce livre le médecin la
liberté et la mort aux éditions plomb
Valérie de pad bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes maître de conférence en droit privé
à l'université Sorbonne Paris Nord
ancienne membre de la commission SICAR
de réflexion sur la fin de vie en France
évidemment Laétitia crupa est resté à
mes côtés Corine Ambert dans dans votre
rapport vous proposez de renforcer la
loi Clais Leonetti vers une sans aller
vers une aide active à mourir pourquoi
ce
choix parce que parce que une évolution
législative nous
paraît d'abord répondre à une commande
présidentielle h pas
forcément et puis parce que nous avons
considéré à travers les audition que
nous avons mené conjointement avec deux
de mes collègues que la loi clonetti
avait quand même été un grand pas vers
une un apaisement de la fin de vie et
qu'elle c'était presque un même si elle
est mal connue et mal appliqu
elle a été votée rappelonsle en 2016 il
y a voilà il y a un peu plus de 7 ans et
on peut tous regretter qu'elle soit mal
connue et mal appliqué mais que ça reste
quand même une chance pour notre
outil législatif d'avoir cette loi et
nous préférions améliorer la loi que de
s'engager en tout cas dans dans le
rapport tel que nous l'avons rédigé vous
avez vu que ce rapport nous l'avons fait
à trois à trois nous étions trois
sénatrices et qui avait un avis
divergent qui est exprimé dans le
rapport mais quià notre niveau nous
onons préféré préféré parler d'une
éthique euh du soin d'une d'une fin de
vie euh apaisé grâce à cette loi làà
parce qu'elle répond quand même à
énormément énormément de situations et
on a toujours mis en exemple une maladie
la maladie de charcos qui est assez
stigmatisant aussi pour les patients
comme étant une raison nécessaire et
suffisante pour faire évoluer la loi
dans notre pays voilà donc c'était la
position de que nous avons prise donc
pas dealisation l'ethanasie on l'a on
l'a on l'a bien compris on pourra
détailler et en reparler évidemment ce
ce débat du du trois qu4 d'heure que dit
le serment d'Hippocrate que font tous
les médecins le jour où ils sont
diplômés je ferai tout pour soulager les
souffrances je ne prolongerai pas
abusivement les agonies je ne
provoquerai jamais la mort délibérément
euh Denis labelle est-ce qu'il faut
changer ce ce serment et surtout changer
la loi pour permettre
le oui le serment il y a pas un serment
il y a plusieurs serments parce que
Hippocrate c'était il longemps évol
régul complètement évolué aujourd'hui
c'est le serment du conseil de l'ORD des
médecins pu le dernière version c'est
2012 c'est marqué comme ça sur internet
avec une correction en 2020 qui est un
peu différente alors bien sûr il y a
marqué cela dans le serment d'Hippocrate
mais il est marqué plein d'autres choses
que les gens oublie et marqué je
respecterai la volonté de mon malade oui
je ne prolongerai pas l'agonie
inutilement or dans la loi classity on
prolonge l'agonie inutilement ce qu'on
noublie de dire c'est un point très très
important ensuite je soulagerai les
souffrances al moi jeais savoir comment
on peut traiter l'agonie réduire
l'agonie sans augmenter les doses de
sédatif et de morphinique là il y a une
incompatibilité bien sûr qu'on aide les
malades à mourir quand on fait de la
sédation efficace donc il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie totale totale et là vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est qu'elle
est mal connue parce que la plupart des
politiques n'ont pas lu le texte
d'application de la Haute Autorité de
Santé de
2018 qui dit que en effet vous allez
déshydrater l'individu vous allez avoir
une sédation fluctuante h c'est-à-dire
d'abord on l'endort puis ensuite s'il se
réveille et ben on lui refait une dose
mais encore faut-il être là pour lui
refaire la dose il est prévu que le
médecin doit passer deux fois par jour
quand il s en ville et trois fois en
épade vous voyez le samedi le dimanche
le médecin passé trois fois en épade
c'est ça la loi actuelle donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut la changer mais bien sûr
c'est absolument inacceptable ce
protocole est inacceptable et puis en
plus elle ne répond pas à des
indications fondamentales les maladie
neurodégénérative c'est pas seulement la
maladie chco c'est beaucoup d'autres
maladies et des gens qui ont des cancers
qui sont à un stat avancé mais qui n'est
pas terminal vous avez demain un cancer
du pancréas qui est évolué qui est
avancé mais vous êtes pas dans une
situation
prémortème il y a des gens qui se disent
ça suffit j'ai pas envie de continuer il
faut les entendre alors qu'avec la loi
aujourd'hui il faut quoi il faut être à
quelques jour il faut quelques heures
c'est marqué hein voilà et les gens
partent à l'étranger justement pour
trouver la solution qu'on leur offre pas
Valérie je l'ai dit en titre là on parle
d'exception d'euthanasie on en parle
alors est-ce que c'est c'est c'est un
terme juridique c'est de quoi il s'agit
ou par on s'est aperçu enfin je beaucoup
beaucoup de rapport l'explique quand des
soins palliatifs de qualité le temps
qu'il faut sont proposés à la personne
et qu'elle les accepte bien souvent la
demande s'arrête mais pas dans tous les
cas et c'est pour ça qu'on dit puisque
le maintien de la demande est
exceptionnel pourquoi ne pas créer une
exception alors là le problème est
juridique parce qu'une exception à quoi
on n pas un grand texte qui nous
interdit l'ethanas ou l'assistance au
suicide et auquel on ferait exception si
on fait exception ce sera à à des
notions beaucoup plus générales comme
l'assassinat l'empoisonnement qui
s'accorde quand même très mal de la
question ne serit-ce que l'élément
intentionnel enfin ce sont des ce sont
des ce sont des crimes sont des voilà on
est dans le pénal c'est pas c'est pas du
tout adapté sans prendre parti sur le le
fond parce que c'est pas votre votre
rôle mais cette loi est-ce qu'elle a
quand même besoin d'être toilettée même
si elle est relativement récente alors
est-ce qu'elle manque de précision par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut dire ça bah de
précision ça c'est les médecins qu'il
savent au moment de l'application je
pense que cette loi est appliquée de
façon très différente d'un d'une équipe
à une autre je sais pour avoir travaillé
avec des réanimateurs qui n'aiment pas
cette procédure parce qu'il s'interroge
sur ce que vit la personne pendant ce
temps de sommeil à quoi rime ce temps de
de sommeil enfin de de sédation qui peut
se prolonger qui se peut se prolonger on
on SAA jamais puisqu'elleevient pas
exactement ce ce que vit la personne et
puis il y a quand même un angle mort
c'est ce que disait le docteur l sans
sans décider parce que je pense que
c'est une question sociétale qui revient
au Parlement c'est vrai qu'il y a des
personnes qui ne veulent plus vivre qui
veulent que leur vie s'arrête leur
pronostic vital est engagé on a aucune
thérapeutique à leur proposer je crois
que la première chose à proposer c'est
la vie avec des soins palliatifs de
qualité mais s'ils échouent
il va bien falloir poser la question à
nos représentants oui Corine est-ce que
c'est c'est ces cas dont on parle
justifie vous nous dites c'est
finalement ce que j'ai compris de votre
première intervention quand vous dites
ça concerne surtout la maladie de
charcoot bon on va pas faire ça pour une
seule maladie alors c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit j'ai dit que c'était c'était
celle qui était mis en avant c'était
celle qui était mise en avant
systématiquement alors qu'effectivement
ce que disait le professeur il y a
d'autres pathologies et donc s'il y a
beaucoup de pathologies qui sont
potentiellement concerné pourquoi ne pas
changer la loi d'après vous
hein parce que je trouve qu' faire
évoluer la loi alors encore une fois la
discussion n'a pas lieu au Parlement
pour l'instant on a fait une mission
d'information conduite avec par trois
sénatrices et même si à l'occasion d'une
proposition de loi il y a quelques mois
euh nous avions eu ce débat ici au Sénat
et c'est à l'issue de cette cette
proposition de loi que j'avais demandé
déjà à conduire une mission
d'information sur les soins palliatifs
et l'état des soins palliatifs dans
notre pays je rappellerai qu'on en est
au 5e plan et qu'on voit bien qu'il y a
des grosses inégalités territoriales on
on va détailler le me VO mais c'est
important parce que euh moi je pense que
on on irait peut-être un peu vite en
besogne même si effectivement il y aura
toujours des
situations difficilees difficile à vivre
pour les patients d'abord pour leur
famille qui justifierait peut-être une
évolution législative je dis bien
peut-être tant qu'on aura pas à un
moment donné permis l'accès au soin
palgatif à tous les patient hm je je
pense que premièrement il est là parce
que c'est pas acceptable aujourd'hui
quand alors qu'on est au 5è plan même si
je sais que c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
qu'on puisse avoir autant de décalage
dans tous les territoires et que les
patients npassent parce que quand ils
rentent dans une unité de soins
palliatif la demande de mourir elle
diminue fortement voir elle disparaît
ouais je je voudrais qu'on reste sur
cette cette notion de de choix
finalement un patient peut-il choisir sa
mort c'est vraiment la question centrale
évidemment de ce de ce débat je vous
propose un témoignage
elle s'appelle Sylvie Richard on est en
juin 2018 c'est une patiente qui est
âgée de 67 ans à l'époque elle est
atteinte d'un cancer incurable elle
vient d'apprendre que sa demande
d'euthanasie a été acceptée en Belgique
on l'écoute ma mort m'appartient et que
je ne laisserai personne me la voler
parce que pour moi c'est ça on me
volerait ma propre mort et ça je me'y
refuse de toutes mes forces tous ces
épidodes de ma vie font que voilà j'ai
toujours dit que le jour serai atteinte
d'une maladie grave je ferais je veux
partir dignement
Denis Lab est-ce que la loi dans sa dans
dans sa forme actuelle prend
suffisamment en compte justement le le
choix du patient non qui a le pouvoir
qui c'est presque la question elle est
un peu triviale mais c'est çaou non
c'est le problème essentiel quand la
maladie devient incurable moi je pense
que le médecin doit rester là il doit
continuer à accompagner son patient et
jusqu'à la fin c'est son rôle pour moi
mais les les cartes sont changé la
maladie est incurable le malade doit
reprendre prendre en main sa destinée ça
me semble fondamental c'est son c'est sa
vie c'est sa dernière liberté c'est une
liberté qui n'empant rien sur les
libertés des autres ça me semble
absolument essentiel et puis une chose
très importante c'est qu'il y a pas
seulement des gens qui souhaitent l'aide
médicale à mourir mais il y a tous ceux
qui ne l'ffont pas mais la loi modifie
leur mentalité en Belgique par exemple
vous n'avez que 2,5 % des gens qui
demandent l'aide médicale à mourir c'est
pas important 4
% en Hollande on arrive à 5 % au Québec
mais quand vous faites des enquêtes
sociologiques 80 % des Belges ne veulent
pas qu'on r viienne en arrière parce que
cette loi désangoisse elle existe depuis
20 ans hein et elle désangoisse
c'est-à-dire que même si je l'utilise
pas le fait même de savoir
qu'éventuellement quelle que soit la
situation je pourrais éventuellement
l'utiliser ça modifie complètement et ça
c'est essentiel encore faut-il Valérie
de avoir dit ce qu'on souhaitait
faire là j'ai
l'impression ai il y a des préalables le
premier vous en parliez je crois qu'on y
viendra c'est de proposer la vie avec
des soins palliatif so piatif ouis et de
savoir ce que veut la personne si elle
se trouve à un moment dans un état de de
vigilance altérée ça dure ça dure
bon je pense qu'on ne touchera jamais
qu'on mettra jamais fin à de façon
anticipée à la vie d'une personne qui
naura pas exprimé sa volonté et pour
l'instant les directives anticipées
c'est plutôt un échec quand même chez
nous pour des raisons cur quoi de
campagne d'informationation et puis je
pense et je le comprends tout à fait oui
on na pas envie de de penser à à sa
propre mort c'est pour ça que je pense
que il faut faire rentrer dans la
culture parce qu'on en a besoin et le
faire rentrer dans la culture je pense
qu'il faut s'adresser aux jeunes par
exemple lors de la journée civique
lorsque la mort paraît loin lorsqu'on a
la force de la jeunesse on s'exprime
plus facilement en en expliquant bien à
l'ensemble des jeunes qu'évidemment ils
vont sûrement évoluer dans leur pensée
et qui pourront revenir à tout moment
sur ces directives mais le
commencer jeune commencer à poser la
question aux personnes je plus Mo on a
envie de anticip aussi clair que ça je
oui quand tant qu'on est jeune ça paraît
tellement loin ça paraî oui mais alors
si on remplit ça à 25 ans on a le droit
changer vie
voilà modifiables jusqu'à leur
application ça il faudra bien le dire
quand même
évidemment corineber sur finalement ça
rejoint un peu la question de de
l'opinion public des Français les
Français sont-ils prêts à à accepter
l'euthanasie moi je répondrai oui si
l'on en croit les sondages qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
oui si l'on en croit les sondages la ce
qui suit c'est est-ce qu'on doit
légiférer selon les sondages h c'est un
sujet il y a un tabou de la fin de vie
il y a un dénis de la mort il y a même
un dénis de la mort dans la formation
des médecins s freur de ma part c'est
qu'on en parle peu c'est quelque chose
qu'on on a mis de côté avant la mort
elle se vivait en famille
euh ça c'est un premier sujet
effectivement ceux qui répondent au
sondage je dis pas qu'il a pas de gens
malades on est tous des malades
potentiel hein mais la la la position la
réponse au sondage est pas forcément la
même quand vous êtes bien portant quand
vous êtes vieillissant d'une maladie
incurable et d'un autre côté ça vient on
atteint presque 9 Français sur 10 hein
le dernier sondage on a cherché ça cet
après-midi c'est quand même oui oui non
mais je conteste pas le dans la marreur
voy je conteste pas les les les les
sondages je je j'essaie juste de de de
de prendre un petit peu de de de de
recul et puis pour me dire bah voilà si
demain je dois je dois examiner ce texte
voter et cetera voilà on a écrit un
rapportme la
responsabilité responsilé parce que
j'entendais que
effectivement dans une
démocratie normale j'allais dire entre
guillemets j'aime j'aime pas le terme
mais effectivement on n'obligera
personne à choisir l'adactive amur si le
patient n'a pas envie évidemment est-ce
que ça pourrait faire l'objet d'un
référendum je ne sais pas je sais pas si
le président de la République en a envie
moi je pense que s'il tarde à sortir le
texte et et à donner le feu vert au
texte c'est peut-être parce qu'il a
peut-être peur de ce que votera le
Parlement et que ça ira au-delà de ce
qu'il peut imaginer on on y reviendra
sur les sur les hésitations d'Emmanuel
Macron farait qu'on parle des pardon je
ma qu'on parle des soins palliatifs avec
avec un chiffre qui est donné par la
société française d'accompagnement et de
soins p 100000 patients y accèdent
chaque année en France ça représente
selon la société française
accompagnement moins d'un tiers de ceux
qui en auraient besoin den Lab est-ce
que c'est pas là l'urgence avant de se
dire est-ce qu'il faut réformer la loi
autoriser l'euthanasie est-ce que c'est
pas mettre plus de moyens sur les so
mais c'est un je dirais c'est un une
panel de solutions qu'il faut trouver
parce que les malades demandent des
choses différentes il y en a qui veulent
aller soatif d'autres qui ne veulent pas
il y a d'autr qui veulent aller chez eux
mourir chez eux il y a d'autres qui
veulent rester à l'hôpital parce qu'il
ils sont bien dans le service qu'
connaissent avec les personnel donc il
faut attentendre cette variété de
demandes son palliatif bien sûr il faut
faut encore que je pense qu'il serait
bon que les médecins se forment au soins
palliatifs de façon ouverte comme en
Belgique c'estàdire qu'il y a pas de
frontière comme c'est en France entre
les soins palliatifs et l'aide médical à
mourir là il y a vraiment un vrai
problème je dirais idéologique donc
laiss paloui mais
réfléchissons tous les gens qui vont en
Belgique et en Suisse sont pas seulement
les gens qui viennent des zones il y a
pas de soins
palliatifs faut être clair h ils
viennent des zones où il y a des soins
palliatifs aussi parce que ça ne
correspond pas à leur demande ouis c'est
important ça veut dire que le jour on
aura résolu le problème des so Palti
dans toute la France et je suis pour on
n'aura pas forcément résolu le problème
de la demande des patients qui ve vous
ent les uns et les autres là-dessus
parce que pas est-ce qu'on peut faire le
lien justement entre la qualité des
soins palliatifs et et les demandes
d'ethanasieou alors en principe non ce
sont deux sujets différents qui sont
malheureusement liés parce que le manque
de soins itif fait souhaiter aux gens de
pouvoir recourir à l'assistance au
suicide si ça se passe trop mal ce sont
deux sujets différents je pense que la
question d'une d'un décès anticipé
médicalement assisté doit se poser quand
toutes les techniques qu'on peut
proposer enfin tous les soins qu'on peut
proposer aux patients ont échoué le
problème c'est comme on peut pas leur
proposer les personnes préfèrent se dire
qu'au pire elles passeront l'étape si
c'est pas possible et plutôt que
d'agoniser dans sur un d'hôpital dans un
couloir elle
préfère décider du moment où ça va
s'arrêter donc si j'ai bien compris vous
on devrait pas c'est tronqué le jeu est
tronqué voilà mais mais quand même vous
nous dites s'il y a de meilleurs soins
palliatifs il y a moins de demande
d'euthanasie même si on ne devrait pas
faire ce c'est ce que disent l'ensemble
des médecins les médecins à noter ça
devrait pas lier puisque les soins enfin
l'assistance au suine ne devrait se
poser
qu'après plusieurs pays on a cité la
Belgique il y a plusieurs pays d'Europe
qui autorisent le euthanasie les
Pays-Bas vous l'avez dit la Belgique
Luxembourg Espagne en Belgique on est à
près de 3000 patients qui ont eu recours
à une euthanasie en 2022 vous nous
l'avez dit don labal ça représente 2,5 %
des décès recensés c'est en constante
augmentation depuis 2003 le le vote de
la loi seul 235 personnes l'avaient
réclamé à ce moment-là sur ce thème je
vous propose un un témoignage je suis
d'an Henry qui est journaliste à à
vakita réalisateur d'un reportage
euthanasie s' exilé pour mourir il est
avec nous en direct bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
avez suivi des personnes qui était en
grande souffrance et qui donc entrepris
ses démarches pour aller mourir
dignement en en Belgique peut-être euh
un peu de pédagogie comment la procédure
est-elle encadrée en Belgique bah euh en
fait en Belgique il faut trois choses
d'abord il faut pouvoir faire la demande
soi-même euh ensuite il faut être
atteint d'une maladie grave et incurable
et il faut qu'elle entraîne des
souffrances physiques ou psychiques
inapaisables ça c'est le cadre légal de
la loi en Belgique donc ça c'est le cas
de légal ça veut dire qu'il y a
plusieurs étapes ça prend du temps il
faut aller plusieurs fois en Belgique
c'est
ça exactement nous par exemple euh on a
suivi le cas de Sandra Sandra elle avait
quasiment mon âge c'est-à-dire la
trentaine et elle habitaé en Bretagne et
elle a dû aller deux fois en Belgique et
donc on a dû traverser toute la France
dans une petite voiture elle pouvait
même plus bouger donc voilà c'est pour
raconter un tout petit peu les les
conditions mais il faut y aller une
première fois rencontrer un médecin
généraliste qui réalisera l'euthanasie
plus un médecin spécialiste ou un
psychiatre à ce moment-là on rédige en
fait la la demande d'euthanasie et puis
normalement techniquement il faut
laisser passer un mois avant l'acte en
lui-même donc ça veut dire qu'il faudra
revenir une une seconde fois merci
beaucoup Alan Henri pour ce témoignage
on a en préparant l'émission On A
chercher combien ça pouvait coûter à des
Français d'aller en Belgique pour
pratiquer l'euthanasie on trouve des
chiffres qui vont jusqu'à 5 à à 6000 €
Corine Ambert ça veut dire qu'il y a une
discrimination face à la mort seul ceux
qui ont les moyens peuvent peuvent aller
en Belgique pour pour faire ce choix oui
si est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
argument pour dire changeons la loi j'ai
pas la réponse oui je non enfin pour moi
çaen est pas un mais effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité si
quelqu'un qui veut avoir recours à
l'euthanasie va avoir des frais y
compris si celui qui veut avoir recours
au suicide assisté se déplacer en Suisse
oui bien sûr il y a il y a des frais et
que c'est pas ouvert à à à tout le monde
euh le le paradoxe parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de de maladie incurable
aujourd'hui tout est fait pour
que les patients aient accès aux
médicaments innovant c'estàdire que d'un
côté on est en train de réfléchir à
légiférer sur sur l'ocitacité ou
l'euthanasie voyez on parle des deux
sujets alors que je pense que dans les
iD du président de la République on
allallait pas jusqu'à l'euthanasie c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il tarde à à à
donner le feu vert pour le texte parce
qu'il a peut-être peur que ça ça lui
échappe d'un côté on fait tout pour
permettre que des maladies incurables
aujourd'hui soient des maladies qu'on
soigne demain faut bien le reconnaître
on fait pas assez pour les soins
palliatifs et oui pour répondre à votre
question bien sûr il y a un coup il est
c'est c'est un fait donc on peut pas
leer il faut noter quand même qu'en
Belgique le contrôle de la procédure se
fait à postériori c'està-dire que même
si si le cheminement n'a pas été bien
fait de toute façon la personne est
décédée quand le contrôle est fait par
la commission Denis labal quand même
est-ce que
le j'allais dire l'offre crée sa propre
demande c'est horrible sur quand on
parle de de de ça mais en même temps
c'est aussi un peu un business dans les
pays qui ont légalisé l'euthanasie donc
est-ce que on peut dire ça par exemple
de la Belgique le fait d'avoir voté
cette loi ben voilà régulièrement le
nombre de patients qui viennent en reste
FA et même s'il augmente où est le
problème je veux dire si il reste dans
des proportions tout à fait raisonnables
où est le problème je pense qu'il y a de
plus en plus de gens qui prennent
conscience de la chose ouis je crois que
ça ne me ça ne me choque pas si
vousoulez on a 2,5 % 4 % de la
population ça reste très faible et puis
je dirais c'est le choix des gens je
vois pas pourquoi on interviendrait pour
leur dire ben non ça ça dépasse le quota
qu'on a prévu et puis les soins
palliatifs ne répondent pas à tout ça
c'est chose important à le dire la
morphine c'est un très bon produit ça
soulage dans 80 % des cas très bien mais
dans 20 % des cas vous avez ulté à
manipuler la morphine c'est pas simple
et puis les soins palliatifs ne règle
pas le problème des maladies
neurodégénératives Val oui mais notre
président a dit il y a quelques mois
maintenant qu'il souhaitait qu'on lui
propose un modèle français de la fin de
vie et je pense qu'un modèle français
c'est un modèle qui va exclure de toute
façon toutes les questions financières
comme l'assistance médicale à la
procréation en France par exemple alors
que que c'est aussi un business ça veut
dire que tout le monde sera égal
face voilà ça VE dire quelque chose à
modèle français ça veut dire respecter
les grands principes qui font notre
droit notamment notre droit médical ou
biomédical respect de la dignité
consentement et exclusion de toute
valeur marchande on le fait pour la vie
je pense qu'on le fera pour la mort on
peut l'espérer alors justement ce modèle
français à quoi pourrait-il ressembler
je propose à Quentin Calmet de nous
rejoindre tout de suite puisque il y a
effectivement un texte qui est en
préparation depuis un certain nombre de
mois qui est aujourd'hui qui est prêt
que contient ce texte Quentin et bien
c'est dur à dire exactement car il
manque toujours les derniers arbitrages
au sommet de l'exécutif donc difficile
de savoir à l'heure où l'on se parle ce
que va contenir le projet de loi
effectivement dont va être saisi le
Parlement dans les prochaines semaines
dans les prochains mois mais dans le
monde on a lu que le texte serait
composé de plusieurs parties il
s'agirait d'abord de développer les
soins palliatifs rebaptisés d'ailleurs
soins d'accompagnement car on le
rappelle en France seul un/ers des
patients concernés disposent d'un accès
à ces soins contre la douleur autre
volet majeur et qui fait toujours
l'objet de d'une attente d'arbitrage
c'est celui qui vise le volet qui vise à
ouvrir l'accès à l'aide à mourir sous
certaines conditions le patient pourrait
alors se voir prescrire un produit létal
sous réserve d'une décision médicale
collégiale Thomas évidemment c'est la
question centrale sous quelle condition
cette aide à mourir pourrait-elle
intervenir voici les pistes qui sont
avancé pour l'heure le patient devrait
être atteint d'une maladie incurable
avoir un pronostic vital engagé avec des
souffrance physique insupportable la
personne ne devrait être dotée d'une
volonté libre et éclairée si elle veut
pas se donner la mort physiquement alors
et bien le projet de loi pourrait
permettre l'intervention d'un
professionnel de santé ou d'un proche
mais bien entendu toutes ces définitions
essentiell elles sont en négociation au
sein même de l'exécutif Emmanuel Macron
qui hésite visiblement Thomas seulle
vraie piste pour l'instant a priori
écarté l'idée de passer par le
référendum pour aller vers ce projet de
loi cette piste avait pourtant été
évoquée par Emmanuel Macron lui-même en
avril 2022 afin de trancher cette
question de société mais on sent
désormais une réticence au sein du
gouvernement écoutez la ministre en
charge de ce dossier agès firmain
lebudau sur notre antenne c'était il y a
15 jours sur un sujet comme celui-là je
la question à poser à répondre par oui
ou par non n'est pas si simple que ça
est-ce que on parle juste d'une
évolution DUP de du du principe parce
que c'est un sujet de société c'est
clairement un sujet de société et les
nombreux débat que je fais auquel je
participe et encore et je vais encore en
continuer à faire vois bien me montre à
quel point je crois que la société est
vraiment pas à évoluer mais tout le
monde s'interroge et c'est légitime
enfin je voulais évoquer une dernière
piste que l'on dont on parle en coulisse
c'est l'idée de proposer au Parlement un
texte à minima sans l'aide active à
mourir et laisser députés et sénateurs
trouver un équilibre sur le projet de
loi lorsqu'il arrivera au Parlement
merci beaucoup Quentin alors je me
tourne évidemment vers vous Corina
est-ce que vous c'est ce que vous vous
demandz finalement que que ce texte soit
soit quasiment écrit par les
parlementaires sans qu'on vous donne là
une ligne directrice trop rigide vous
connaissez l'attachement du
parlementou mais non mais c'est on
pourrait dire aussi que le Président de
la République vous pardon c'est très
trivial ce que je dire mais vous refile
la patate chaude quoi voyzêre ce qui lui
fait peur aussi c'est peut-être ce qui
lui fait peur je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'on a pas le texte à l'heure qu'il est
on devait l'avoir avant la fin de l'été
on voit bien les les les les hésitations
et ça s'entend le sujet est difficile
saboè vous l'avez rappelé les sondages
vont en faveur d'une aide active à
mourir pour
autant la la la la discussion et même
c'est un sujet sociétal difficile c'est
quand même lui qui l'a mis sur la table
je pense que il sait plus comment s'en
sortir il y a quand même il y a dans
dans ce texte on vient de le voir avec
Quentin il y a à la fois le
développement des soins palliatifs et
puis la question de de l'aide à mourir
il y a un collectif qui représente
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
professionnels de santé qui s'est dit
choqué par ce mélange des genres de
est-ce que vous aussi ça vous choque que
ce soit dans le même texte mais non je
pense que c'est absolument indispensable
que ce soit dans texte bien sûr pouroi
mais vous savez parce que c'est le
problème de la fin de vie la fin de vie
sa Sissonne pas on a tendance à voir les
problèmes les un après les autres soin
palliatif d'un côté il y a ceci non le
malade choisit c'est lui qui est le
maître de la situation ça il faut bien
se le mettre dans la tête et je suis
très étonné pour juste pour reprendre ce
que vous dites que le Président de la
République n'est pasis
la situation qui a eu au mois d'avril
1900 2021 où il y a eu au Parlement la
le projet dans une niche parlementaire
de de Olivier fallorni où tous les
parlementaires se sont levés il lui ont
fait une ovation debout il y a eu que 40
personnes qui étaient contre il y a eu
4000 amendements il avait l'occasion
rêvé pour laisser le Parlement continuer
à travailler et je n'ai pas compris
personnellement pourquoi on n'a pas été
au-delà alors justement on va essayer
d'analyser ça avec vous laéticia je vous
propose d'abord d'écouter le président
de de la République on est juste après
la convention citoyenne parce qu'il a
aussi convoqué une c'était une promesse
de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron et puis
ensuite il y a eu cette convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie on écoute
Emmanuel Macron je demande au
gouvernement en lien avec les
parlementaire désigné par le président
du Sénat et la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui avec leur conférence des
présidents auront à faire ce travail
transpartisan de mener une œuvre de
coconstruction sur la base de cette
référence solide
qui est celle de la convention citoyenne
et en lien avec toutes les parties
prenantes je souhaite que ce travail
permettre de bâtir un projet de loi
d'ici à la fin de l'été 2023 fin de
l'été 2023 évidemment bon voilà on a on
est quelques mois plus tard pourquoi
laticia Emmanuel Macron tarde-t-il à
donné son feu vert la nouvelle échéance
il l'a donné c'est la fin du mois de
décembre donc c'est dans quelques
semaines pourquoi il tarde écoutez c'est
la question que se pose toute la
majorité été Thomas on ne comprend pas
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron tergiverse
alors qu'il a le texte de Madame Germain
lebaudau la ministre chargé des
professions de santé depuis 2 mois
presque sur son bureau et elle
attend voilà Agnès firman lobodo elle
attend depuis plusieurs mois d'avoir un
un projet de loi à défendre donc
peut-être première piste que je vous
propose le timing ça va être comp
compliqué comme je vous disais avant la
fin décembre quand on interroge l'é
Lisée il dit pourtant tous disent ce
sera fin décembre or le 13 décembre il
faut quand même qu'il y ait l'aval du
Conseil d'État le 13 décembre il y a
l'inscription deivg dans la Constitution
donc il reste la date du 20 décembre
est-ce que c'est une bonne date juste
avant Noël pour un projet sur la fin de
vie pas si sûr et puis il y a aussi la
forme Thomas qui freinerait le président
est-ce que on est encore en train de se
demander s'il faut parler de suicide
assisté ou d'eutthanasie et ça a fait
l'objet notamment d'une passe d'armes
dans la dernière réunion
interministérielle sur le sujet la
semaine dernière apparemment qui a été
mouvementé parce que il y a encore des
résistances dans la majorité par exemple
la ministre des solidarité et des
familles Aurore berger est contre une
nouvelle loi et elle fait partie de ce
camp qui pense que la loi actuelle
suffit si elle est bien appliquée et
laisse beaucoup de possibilités alors il
y a des résistances internes dans sa
majorité et puis Emmanuel Macron craint
peut-être aussi la réaction d'autorité
morale c'est ce qui se murmure en tout
cas dans son cercle très proche
c'est-à-dire qu' a reçu plusieurs
responsables religieux et tous le
dernier en date c'est vraiment il y a
pas très longtemps c'était le grand
Rabin Aï corcia tous sont contre et donc
ça freinerait encore une fois le
président de la République mais on l'a
dit c'était l'une de ses promesses de de
candidat il veut quand même proposer une
loi un chantier pour la fin de son
cquena c'est là que le bas blesse parce
que selon mes sources quis sont diverses
variés proches du pouvoir elles sont
toutes unanimes Emmanuel Macron dans le
fond serait contre une évolution de la
loi contre une nouvelle loi et Brigitte
Macron son épouse également je vous
parle là de leur intime conviction hein
donc évidemment ce sera jamais mis à
jour la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron finalement a
lancé ce chantier parce que vous le
disiez tout à l'heure 9 Français sur 10
le veulent est-ce qu'il l'a fait parce
que c'était c'était poussé par le peuple
et c'est un casassus Bell pour Emmanuel
Macron finalement et c'est pour ça qu'
tergiverse la question qu'il se pose
elle est simple faut-il faire cette loi
pour répondre à une demande populaire
alors que lui-même est intimement
convaincu du contraire et je vous
propose encore cette question de façon
un peu plus large en guise de conclusion
de mon éito dans un régime présidentiel
un président peut-il lancer un chantier
aussi fondamental que celui de la fin de
vie alors que lui-même est contre voire
et pétri de doute ouais ça ça pose une
une question qui est on parlait de
pouvoir den label est-ce que c'est la
décision d'un seul homme parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est c'est on est dans
ce moment on est dans ce moment
particulier le dessin de ce texte dépend
de de d'un seul homme le présent de la
République alors qu'il y a eu la
Convention sur la fin de vie alors qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de consultations auprès
de la ministre et cetera et cetera on
oublie un petit peu que nous sommes dans
une République laïque h pour moi laïque
ça veut dire tolérance c'està-dire qu'on
tolère les religions toutes les
religions et ceux qui ne sont pas
croyants or si on nétudie pas le
problème de la fin de vie à la lumière
de la laïcité en effet on tombe dans les
blocs idéologiques et à ce moment-là on
se laisse influencer par l'un ou par
l'autre non et on est dans une
République laïque où il faut étudier
voilà qu'est-ce qui correspond à la
liberté à l'égalité et à la fraternité
il n'est pas normal que le pouvoir
religieux en l'occurrence pèse de tout
son poids dans l'évolution de cette loi
c'est son droit de se manifester c'est
son tout à fait son responsabilité de
dire ce qu'il pense mais il doit pas en
Belgique ils se sont retirés de du débat
ils ont dit voilà nous avons donné notre
avis maintenant c'est à la société de se
prononcer et la France reste tout même
avec un poids religieux multireligieux
très lourd moi j'ai été au repas du
président de la République j'étais le
seul par rapport à tous les
représentants des religions monothéistes
qui tout étaient d'accord du reste c'est
extraordinaire c'est la première fois
que j'ai vu toutes les religions
monothéistes sur un même point d'accord
mais euh voilà je pense que nous sommes
dans une République laïque ouverte et ça
il faudrait que le Président de la
République ne l'oublie pas alors ce
poids des religions il s'exprime
notamment l'église catholique je vous
propose de d'entendre Éric de
moulinbeaufort qui préside la Conférence
des évêques de France c'était le 8
novembre dernier lors de leur assemblée
plainère lançons un appel pour relire
notre inquiétude non moins grande devant
le projet de loi en préparation
concernant la fin de vie une société
humaine doit être fraternelle pour tous
et pour toutes jusqu'à la fin de la vie
et promouvoir l'aide active à vivre tout
en se gardant d'un certain goût pour la
mort inhérent à notre humanité marquée
par le péché
Emmanuel Macron qui a également
rencontré le pape François à plusieurs
reprises la dernière fois c'était à à
Marseille à la fin de de l'été Corine
Ambert est-ce qu'il cède au aux
arguments finalement de des religieux
des religions monothéistes et notamment
l'église catholique Emmanuel Macron je
sais pas si c'est toutes les religions
sont exprimés nous les avons auditionné
dans le cadre de notre mission au Sénat
elles ont effectivement été unanimes et
sont prononcé compes pour autant elles
ne participent pas au vote demain si le
texte sera est débattu au au au Sénat
par contre je pense qu'il a ses propres
convictions et qu'il est piégé et il est
piégé par la Convention citoyenne parce
que il a déjà fait la convention
citoyenne sur l'environnement il a reçu
150 et quelques proposition en a retenu
une faire une autre organiserut c'est
pas tout à fait vrai mais bon c'est pas
grave je vous laisse la responsabilité
il organ mais c'est ce qu'
enfin il a il il organise une autre
convention
citoyenne s'il avait pas été à l'écoute
on lui aurait dit à quoi bon organiser
des conventions citoyennes bien ça ne
sert à rien le peuple n'est pas écouté
ou même si contrairement à ce qui a été
dit elle a pas complètement été tir au
sort c'est 2000 personnes qui ont été
tir au sort parmi les 2000 les 150 ou
170 ont été
choisis aussi mais il il est piégé il
est piégé par sa promesse il est piégé
par la Convention citoyenne et ça
correspond pas à ses conviction alors
oui est-ce que le pouvoir c'est le choix
d'un homme c'estes convictions
personnell c'est pour ça qu' il arrive
pas et je pense qu'ensuite l'autre piège
qui peut l'attendre
c'est le vote du Parlement et de ce que
sera le texte sorti du Parlement oui et
après je veux bien vous entendre sur ce
que vient de de nous dire den la sur le
le la République laïque est-ce que le
poids finalement des des religions n'est
pas trop important dans une République
laïque dans un débat comme
celui-là par rapport à la laïcité la
laïcité n'exclut pas non plus les
religion non ah ben non non voilà alors
est-ce qu'il est trop important pas
assez important mais en tout cas
pourquoi pourquoi ne les pourquoi ne pas
les auditionner pourquoi ne pas écouter
leur avis je dis pas qu'il faut pas les
auditionner question est-ce qu'il pèse
pas trop voilà c'est ce que je reprends
l'argument
de parmi les arguments justement
de l'Église catholique que j'ai pu
trouver là en préparant l'émission cet
après-midi il a y a cette idée Valérie
de de dire attention on est dans une
extension du domaine de la violence
légitime qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut répondre à ça non je pense pas
qu'il s'agisse d'une violence voilà pour
moi la violence n'a pas n'a pas la place
dans le dans le raisonnement la violence
ressentie par les personnes c'est pas
être entendu d'une façon ou d'une autre
pas être respecté dans leur volonté dans
dans leur personne ce qui est violent
c'est de pas pouvoir accéder à des soins
palliatifs quand on en a besoin ça c'est
violent oui mais sinon non d'ailleurs il
y a une question rche dire oui je crois
que c'est un texte qui va être
particulièrement difficile à écrire
parce qu'il suffit pas d'acter la
volonté des Français 9/ 10 ça tout le
monde l'a compris mais il va falloir
l'acter dans la grille de notre droit et
de nos de nos grands principes déjà
c'est ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
et il y a une chose dont on n pas parlé
c'est que ça se fera pas sans les
médecins voilà com il va bien falloir
trouver un consensus
oui tout les M mdecin accepteront
d'accompagner ils le disent leur
patients jusqu'au mais ceux qui refusent
vont aller chercher les autres non on va
pas faire des des autonator enfin je
veux dire c'est c'est pas les médecins
qui acceptent d'accompagner leurs
patients qui accepteront d'accompagner
tous les patients alors qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire on va construire des endro plus
on va pas non plus sanctionner les
médecins qui refuser la PR dis juste que
c'est très compli très difficile
maintenant on trouvera je compte sur
vous ou jeis juste pour dire une chose
la violence et la maladie h c'est ça la
violence c'est la souffrance c'est ce
qu'on soit au jour le jour c'est ça
qu'on est obligé de traiter et le le
allez-y ouais non mais et puis si
toutefois le texte était dans le sens
d'une aide active à mourir après on le
voit dans d'autres dans d'autres pays
c'est c'est les
extensions des situations
qui correspondrait pour les patients à
la possibilité de de demander cette ad
qui va mourir là vous l'avez vu des
personnes majeures mais la question de
de l'aide active à mourir chez des
mineurs se pose et et existe dans dans
certains pays voyez et et on met un pied
et puis jusqu'où ça s'arrête moi j'avais
été frappé lors de nos auditions par un
philosophe qui nous a mais les choses
sont assez simples il suffit de
légiférer dans trois grandes situations
et dans l'ordre euh les personnes
lourdement
handicapées les personnes atteintent de
maladie incurabl et l'extrême vieillesse
vous voyez qu' on parle plus que de
maladie incurable on voit tout de suite
vers quoi ça pourrait ouvrir donc vous
dites attention à une dérive potentielle
qu'est-ce que rép et ben je dis que les
dérives elles sont aujourd'hui là parce
que on parle toujours de la dérive
possible de l'aide active à mourir mais
on ne parle pas de la dérive de la vie
coûte que coûte de l'ararnement thé
lbert l'affaire Alain coq qui est depuis
36 ans grab et on lui dit non monsieur
il faut attendre encore un petit peu ce
sont des dérives de ceux qui soutiennent
la vie cû C cûe et ça on n parle pas
mais c'est épouvantable on oublie de
dire qu'on ne répond pas à la demande de
ses patients Alain co justement il est
mort en 2021 par suicide assisté il a dû
aller en Suisse effectivement 35 ans
d'une maladie incurable il avait écrit
une lettre non seulement au président la
République mais aussi au gouvernement au
parlementaires français et il avait été
interviewé par la FP 2 mois avant sa
mort je vous propose de l'entendre dans
les depuis 50 ans on leur on leur
enseigne que la mort est un échec du
médecin c'est pas le
cas ça fait partie du cycle de la vie le
cycle de la vie n'est pas un
échec le rôle d'un médecin c'est
d'accompagner le patient dans ses
pathologies de le guérir quand il le
peut et de soulager quand il ne peut
plus Valérie de jeis vous laissz le mot
de la conclusion il nous reste 30
secondes vous avez parlé des médecins ça
ne se fera pas sans les médecins est-ce
qu'il faut aussi les former un peu
différemment sur ces questions
certainement certainement maintenant
pour ce qui est des
dérives je suis sans doute naïve mais je
fais assez confiance à à notre système à
notre système juridique qui notamment en
bioéthique en biomédecine a déjà fait
ses preuves donc je pense qu'on trouvera
un modèle français merci beaucoup on va
terminer sur cette note optimiste je
rappelle Denis lab titre de votre livre
le médecin la liberté et la mort livre
qui est publié aux éditions plomb voilà
c'est la fin de ce sens public je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat et
puis noter que demain l'invité de la
matinale Dorian mansini sera le général
Dominique trinquant l'ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
merci
[Musique]